to live coverage from Tucson the ship is
about to sail and you are on board get
that yeah
brothers and sisters welcome to the best
at the Tucson Festival of Books and my
name is John Nichols I write for the
Nation magazine I wrote a book about
Donald Trump and the people around him
horsemen of the Trump pocalypse we're
not going to talk about my book we're
talking about some other ones here I got
to go through some bureaucracy at the
start because we're on c-span which you
may apply because c-span is a very good
thing for books
[Applause]
I'm getting old enough to read these
things without my glasses and we want to
thank the Research Corporation for
science advancement and Kaede industries
Andy and Stuart shackin who are right
here in the front row and they have got
the sponsor this particular we are
delighted with them I know that every
one of you have already purchased copies
of the books that we are talking about
today but you will want to purchase the
second one outside when they when the
authors go to the book tent and most of
you know where that is I think that is
the guts of what we have to tell you
upfront except it says very short intros
authors don't like long introductions on
the on the instruction sir that
surprises me but for those of you who
know me and know the stuff I've written
about you know that I'm a structuralist
I am very very concerned about the
structures of our economy our democracy
our society and I think they usually
tell us more about where we're going
than a personality driven individual
focused journalism or politics right I
think structures matter more than
individuals except when we're talking
about Donald Trump because Donald Trump
this is the truth of it Donald Trump has
shown us no matter what you think about
the guy the strengths and
vulnerabilities of the American
political process he his presidency is
different than any before it and the big
question is does is it the beginning of
something else or is it a nominally
we'll find that out today because we
have literally the smartest Trump
watchers in the country with us and at
this point when you're not mumbling to
each other and checking your phones and
stuff like that you really focused so
I'm gonna ask them the core question up
front will start with Katy tur and by
the way not to insult the guys on the
panel but everyone I talked to outside
said is this the Katy tur panel
[Laughter]
katie has written an incredible book
unbelievable I have I read the book and
I've taught a little bit of journalism
in my life and I will tell you flat-out
that is interesting as it is regards
Donald Trump it is a textbook for young
people coming into journalism today it
really tells you the reality because she
Katie opens up and is very very honest
about how annoying and painful and
difficult it can be but also how
exhilarating and exciting Katie's gonna
answer our first question here and then
we'll ask the others as well what is it
for these folks we're gonna go into a
lot more stuff here but what is it the
one thing that you really want these
people to know after a year and a half
or two years of following Donald Trump
it has been I think it's been three
years gosh at work it doesn't when
you're running up on three years as if I
don't know how to use one of these thank
you very much sir I think we're running
up we're close to three years covering
Donald Trump the one thing that that
people don't understand about him or
don't want to understand about him is
the simplest thing Donald Trump is not
complicated
he's not a complicated person and when
you're watching television or you're
reading newspapers or you're reading
analysis or opinion pieces or talking to
your friends and everyone's trying to
figure out why he's doing a certain
thing or saying a certain thing it's a
very simple answer he's saying it
because he wants to figure out or he's
promoting himself essentially how does
this one thing affect Donald Trump not
how does this one thing affect the
economy or the auto industry or foreign
policy or equality it's all in relation
to how it affects Donald Trump it's a
zero-sum game is a good for Donald Trump
individually and for his business is it
not good for Donald Trump and so if you
look at things going forward through
that lens he'll be much easier to
understand gay teacher and by the way
one other quick little follow-up on that
on the day that you're the one on his
mind are the two or three or four or
five days he talks about you
very bluntly and and should we think of
that as an accomplishment or a failure
what is that it's in a mix on right some
people will say that's the greatest
honor to have Donald Trump and soul at
you he brought up 10,000 people however
many people it is listen I I think he if
he's on your radar because you've done
something he does not like it's not a
bad thing I guess because he often
doesn't like the truth and if you're
telling the truth and he calls you out
for telling the truth I mean thank you
for confirming that I'm telling the
truth
basically date eater Joshua green by the
way I should mention that Katie Turk but
before we get to Joshua cuz he's rockin
good guy
but because it's you know this is this
the kid eater
no no but before everybody knows that
Katie did such a good job covering the
campaign that they gave her a show on
MSNBC and now it is highly rated an
incredibly successful show because we
should tell your your affiliate link you
to PM MSNBC East Coast time I believe
that as noon here in Arizona correct me
if I'm wrong and you should watch don't
die daylight saving time Arizona has
multiple times figured out 2 p.m. in
East and then you figure out and and 5
p.m. for Meet the Press daily every
Monday anyway Josh Joshua green the
author of devil's bargain now yeah
I think he won the cover contest because
this is this is a very we were just
saying before there's suddenly a little
bit of a Netflix kind of poster thing
going on here with Donald Trump and
Steve banning Joshua works for he has
worked for the Atlantic he's a Bloomberg
writer he's on CNN a great deal you've
seen him all over the place the thing
about this book that is so significant
is it isn't just about Trump it's about
a lot more going on around him but again
we're gonna begin with that core
question what's the one thing you want
these people to to keep with them
through this whole journey sure well
first of all is my mic working okay for
everybody okay real quick by the way my
mother also calls it the Katie to repeal
honey I saw so it's even even in my own
family I'm getting a second going but
that's okay I think it was so the one
takeaway I think that that I learned
writing the book and kind of thinking
about you know my book essentially tells
a story of how Steve Bannon and Donald
Trump came together and triumphed in a
way that even those of us are at least
me who had front-row access to it didn't
see happening in real time I didn't I
didn't think that Donald Trump was gonna
win until about 10:00 p.m. on election
night and then it hit me like a
thunderbolt and oh my god so that would
make you an American that would make me
merry yeah I think in in reassessing all
that happened what's most important to
know about Donald Trump is he he is an
incredible intuitive politician and when
I was at on the campaign trail at the
Stadium events you know when you when
you experienced them through the medium
of cable television often the focus was
on violence in the crowds and were there
racists there bikers and all he's gonna
what I saw at these event was somebody
who brought to mind almost one of these
these great American rhetorician 'he's
of the 1890s you know William Jennings
Bryant or somebody who'd go out there
day after day after day and you could
see him testing things out and seeing
what resonated with the audience and I
tell the story in the book of how the
wall came to be and it was a an idea
that was given to him by some of his
advisers the Trump initially wasn't too
interested in but he
in Iowa I might know who that advisory
well it is sam nunn burg has anybody
heard of Sam number he's he's suddenly
very famous it's done very well has it
he's kept himself out of jail quite it
he's on quite a press tour quarter press
to indeed so so Sam came up with this
idea for the wall and Trump was
initially kind of cool to it but he
tried it out in an Iowa and it really it
brought down the house and Trump could
see that and he began to riff on an
excerpt I'm gonna build a wall and I'm
gonna make Mexico pay for it it became a
bigger hit you know I'm gonna build a
wall nobody builds like Trump and so
you'd see at the stadium of him testing
out these different lines and seeing
what worked and what didn't and I think
it forged a connection that a lot of us
didn't appreciate in real time and it
put you know an issue set for fronting
illegal immigration and crime and in
things that weren't really on the radar
of a lot of mainstream political people
in Washington and to me that that was
really trumps gift as a campaigner and
you can see him trying and struggling to
continue this while he's in the White
House he doesn't have that visser
visceral connection to a stadium
audience like he wants to so I think
he's having a little bit more trouble
with the booney talks about Colin
Kaepernick and NFL players kneeling and
now his new thing seems to be trying to
push the death penalty for drug dealers
it's that same kind of like what is what
is gonna make the crowd roar and I and I
think that remains one of his talents
and and sometimes a scary one
Joshua green you also attracted the
attention of the president yeah on
Twitter I did what the funding my book
just came out in paperback and the
publisher at the stadium we're gonna use
this Trump tweet you know referencing
you or subtweeting you whatever your
book is a blurb and I thought well sure
why not and then I got the book and I
opened up and it's an actual picture of
the tweet with all three tweets they've
sort of reprinted and seized appropriate
because that's really trumps medium for
for it for anything as Twitter thanks
for viewing books and in 140 characters
or he's a credit ya big reader I'm sure
and
I was actually told by somebody in the
White House after the book came out and
it caused a little trouble you know
Trump hasn't read your book but he did
look at the cover and he saw that Steve
Bannon got equal billing and he's angry
about yeah kind of went deeper into your
book than some well you bet you should
remind the crowd of the kind words that
he had for you what I remember I did it
all night yeah that the rough the rough
criticism the tweet was you know this
guy's writing about all the geniuses
that helped me in my campaign I'm the
only genius you know sad thanks Joshua
green David Kay Johnson hello my back
you'll note that this panel is called
the making of Trump or something like
that I you know it's obviously a
variation on Teddy White's great books
the making of the president and stuff
like that or on David K Johnson's book
the making of Trump and David's got a
couple books that are that are in play
right now I know how much they're in
play cuz last week I was in Germany and
I was in a train station in Hamburg and
they had a couple of Trump books but the
one on top way on display David was
making a trumpet German so you're you're
nailing it worldwide his new book is the
one that says in German on the cover a
dictator and waiting yeah not that
David's a critic and you wouldn't think
that from his the title of his new book
which is it's even worse than you think
David safety flask is in this initial
fortune here because you are the guys
known Trump the longest what's the one
thing you want to make sure that these
people take away first off we've got
he's not complicated
he's an instinctual politician David Kay
Johnson well first of all everything
that Katie and Josh said absolutely
completely agree I think that the most
important thing beyond those two points
that people need to understand and I do
not understand why this has never
appeared in the New York Times the LA
Times The Washington Post The Wall
Street Journal has been on MSNBC and CNN
because I've said it on those places but
not on PBS ABC or NBC however if you
lived in Germany you would know this
because it's been on TV dare in fact
twelve foreign television news crews
have come to my home in Rochester New
York and interviewed me about this all
throughout the 1980s Donald Trump was
very deeply entangled with a major
international cocaine trafficker he did
favors for this man he wrote a letter
saying he was a stand-up guy and a
credit to the community his case was
mysteriously transferred from Ohio to
the New Jersey federal courtroom of
Judge Mary Ann Trump Barry
and while she recused herself the mules
in the drug deal drug trafficking served
up to 20 years this guy 18 months and
everything Donald Trump did makes
absolutely no sense as a casino owner
who should have lost his license for
what he did but it makes perfect sense
if they were both in the drug business
together and why this is not major news
is to me absolutely astonishing to this
day Donald Trump's criminal
entanglements and they go back in his
family three generations to his
draft-dodging pimp grandfather why this
is not major news I don't know I mean
the idea that we would have someone with
Donald Trump's criminal background a man
who's been twice tried for income tax
fraud and lost both cases civil trials
confessed to sales tax fraud why what
most important thing to take away is to
understand that Donald Trump is not just
the greatest con artist in history but
he is one of the most successful
criminals in the United States and here
he is the head of our government what
does that tell us about us Wow David
Kate Johnson
you know you know David when you're
talking like that it makes me think it
it's even worse and then you think okay
you know why we have that title because
the book is about our government it's
not about the White House
talk about him personally and you know
what that's why I love you because I am
in fact a structuralist and I think
there's a lot more going on here than
just one guy but let me follow up with
David on one thing now that we've got
our basics down right not complicated
instinctual politician crook all right
you've known David you've known Trump
thirty years come June yeah and and do
you think when you call him Donald on TV
that that annoys him you do that when
here if you were not Katie's show you'd
be going yeah Donald does this yeah yeah
on the other hand you know I was on a
platform 11 months ago in San Francisco
with Nancy Pelosi you know what I called
her Nancy Nancy
so you're just all the Senators their
first names a lot and I find out later
that I mean it's not appropriate from
their press well here's what I think
about that it's interesting in senators
representatives in the President as well
as the Supreme Court weird their bosses
they're our subordinates we have
temporarily imbued them with power but
they work for us we don't work for them
David at the filing up with you just a
little bit more here on you've known him
for a very very long time were you
surprised when he ran for president
United States no Donald's been talking
publicly since 1985 by running for
president you Donald really believes not
only he should be President but he
should run the whole world because he is
genetically superior the rest of us is
he and one of his sons have both said
and and Donald literally believes that
you know he's entitled here to all this
and on the day that he announced in 2015
I sat there watching this live on TV and
said oh my god he might pull this off
and I started writing pieces about two
dozen of them to journalists saying ask
these questions and one of them was 21
questions for Donald Trump
and nobody did except
Cruz and Marco Rubio yeah speaking of
Ted Cruz and Marco Rubio I actually I I
believe that the the term little Marco
was actually tested out again initially
on Katy tur because you were little Katy
right he used to call you that for me
little bob Corker a little kim jong get
the little thing is a big one for him
yeah that's yeah but that isn't really
when I asked you you have said coming
off what David just said that Donald
Trump if I get it right it's he doesn't
you may surprise you sometimes it isn't
shock you yeah and that you were not
shocked when he became president no and
I mean I kind of just want this whole
panel to I want David to talk the whole
time and tell me everything you know
everything more you know about Donald
Trump no no and I think David I think
you'd agree with this he he he he is not
shocking if you follow him I mean
nothing he does is out of character
nothing at all
no he's the one well I guess one of the
few good things you can say about Donald
Trump is he's consistent and and you
know you you know that everything at the
end of the day is about Donald yeah
mm-hmm but it's true I mean the my
button is bigger than yours tweet which
is so childish and scary frankly because
you're talking about nuclear weapons
that's not shocking it's surprising
still that we have somebody in
government who speaks like that and who
takes to Twitter for his every whim but
what Donald Trump has done is not
shocking and all you have to do is go
back and look at the way he's comported
himself over the years look at though I
mean look at the way he comported
himself during the election he would
bury one controversy with another
controversy he didn't like that headline
he would say something even more
outrageous if Hillary Clinton was dare
she get getting a day of press coverage
and he was not he would come out and say
something it could be two examples one
was President Obama was gave a speech on
foreign policy and the for the fight
against terrorism right after Baker's
happened and that was a Sunday night
Monday morning Monday afternoon early
afternoon everybody's talking about the
Obama speech I have one of those rare
days where I can go get lunch
it's December 7th 2015 and if that date
rings a bell you'll remember it's not
just Pearl Harbor day it's a day Donald
Trump announced that he wanted a Muslim
ban yep so suddenly the the news
coverage which had been all about
President Obama was now all about Donald
Trump he succeeded in pulling it back
towards him one of the other examples
that that looms large in my mind is the
middle of the summer in 2016 during the
Democratic National Convention usually
the other candidate who's not having
their convention takes a few days off
and lets that candidate have their
couple days and plans on a strategy for
the general election it's just kind of
tradition it's it's the way you did
thank you at that point you should have
known that Donald Trump he has a press
conference on July 27 2016 and this is
in the middle of the DNC
Hillary Clinton's getting all of the
attention and he goes up and he says
Russia if you're listening I'd love to
see those emails so the news cycle was
pulled back in his direction once more
he doesn't like being out of the news
for a few days for a few hours so he'll
go quiet on Twitter for a day or two
days three days maybe he'll be calm but
inevitably when he sits himself in front
of a television and doesn't have a full
schedule or even a moderately full
schedule and his golfing or has an
excessive amount of executive time he
will he will start shooting his mouth
off because his opinions he is he is all
in he cannot stop himself he's like a
seven year old that's having a temper
tantrum he needs to be heard he needs
you to pay attention to him it doesn't
matter if it's bad attention or good
attention he wants you to be focusing on
him at all times what was the original
question no no that was essentially I
made it look there was we're talking
about a whole bunch other stuff but I
like where you went sorry I'm keeping
that but I am bringing Josh in here
because Josh what we've gotten from
David and
Katty here is an image of a guy who is
you know kind of wholly formed within
himself right he is he it it comes into
his head and it's nationwide one of the
things I love about your book though is
that you I think you established very
well in your book because of your
extraordinary access to Steve Bannon who
else was a guy who has pretty big ego
but but that it appears that that at
some point in this campaign Trump did
need something more than himself he
needed a strategist who at the very
least had some ideas and what you bring
into this is all of what these folks are
saying but also this other element of
this this remarkable individual
remarkable maybe in the small are not
the capital our talk to us a little
about that well I think you know I argue
in the book that Bannon assented that
Trump wouldn't be President had Steve
Bannon not connected with him and I make
that argument for two reasons one is
that if you look at Trump and what he
has talked about since 1985 and what he
believes and you you hear a lot of the
same notes struck that we're being real
ripped off and foreign trade deals you
know back in the 80s it was Japan now
it's China you know he'll make better
deals you know the one element that I
think Bannon brought in when he met
first met Trump in 2011 and began
informally advising him was the issue of
illegal immigration Trump just didn't
talk about this and wasn't interested in
this if you go back and look at the
things he tweeted about in 2011-2012 not
that any of you would spend your time
that way but if you did you would see
that there aren't these kind of tweets
in the beginning in 2013 when Bannon
really stepped up and began advising him
regularly and when Trump in hindsight
it's clear became serious about running
for president you see this issue emerge
and it was so powerful in the Republican
presidential primary if you remember his
announcement he comes down the elevator
and Trump Tower with all the pink marble
around him the first thing he does is
call Mexicans rapists and it became this
you know bumper-to-bumper notorious
headline that I think announced from the
get-go a that the Trump was going to be
a campaign or a candidate unlike any
other but be that he's going to put this
issue in the fraud
his campaign and this happened in part
because Bannon was egging him on and
spurring him along and as soon as that
happened you know there were all these
statements condemning you know john john
mccain came out and condemned them and
paul ryan said it was ugly and
disgusting and rather than you know back
away or trying to make amends Trump
doubled down and Bannon arranged for him
to travel down to the Mexican border at
Laredo Mexico is really the first media
trip with campaign and beds and
everything were you on that you were to
go down to the to go down to the Mexican
border in his van and put it to me say
to Mexico's face what Trump had just
said on the escalator after he came down
so I think that was very important the
other thing that vannin brought to him I
think is that Bannon had spent years and
years studying how to tear down Hillary
Clinton he was the mastermind of this
book Clinton cash that had come out just
as Clinton was announcing her
presidential campaign it had you know
tarnished and impugn her reputation by
you know connecting her and her
foundation to that change
there was a front-page story in The New
York Times we Benin is a very clever guy
when it comes to media and propaganda
studies the old Nazi and Soviet
propaganda filmmakers and I think what
what
Bannen brought to him at this key moment
after the Republican convention when
Trump was down about eight or ten points
in the polls was he was able to come in
and take over the campaign and focused
Trump on a target and you know one of
trumps talents is tearing people apart
when he can keep his attention trained
on one person Ben and by virtue of the
fact that he'd spent years studying how
to attack Hillary Clinton actually had
ideas you know to arm Trump with and
when Trump gets warmed up on attacking
somebody as we've all seen he can be
very effective in doing that so I think
he doesn't like to be handled though so
he had to walk up quite a tightrope he
does and what people don't get about Ben
and I think from from the public image
is he's actually a guy who's very smart
and has a lot of personal charisma but
also had been an investment banker in a
movie finance guy so he had a lot of
experience manipulating the egos of
brash ambitious rich men
and I think was able to maneuver Trump
in a way that didn't feel to Trump as if
he were being maneuvered to to you know
keep him trained on Hillary Clinton you
know in a way that we saw work I mean
across you know the entire fall the
polls were just closed and closing
closing closing maybe if you're smarter
than I am you could you could imagine
you know Trump winning before election
night I never believed that he was going
to until the end but in the end that
that was enough to get Trump elected if
you subtract Bannon from that equation
I'm skeptical that it happen well the
enthusiasm for Hillary Clinton wasn't
there and what we were seeing on the
campaign trail was was the and in state
like Arizona this complete and utter
devotion to Donald Trump it didn't
really matter what he was saying they
weren't watching the news to be
convinced that he wasn't fit for office
if they were watching the news or
reading the paper and and seeing an
opinion that they did not agree with or
seeing me or anyone else be critical of
what he was doing it only dug them in
further I mean they felt like Donald
Trump was fighting for them and Donald
Trump was being attacked and while he
was being attacked they were being
attacked
he was warding it off but then another
thing that helps in the end of the
campaign not just ban it and what Bannon
certainly helped Donald Trump focus on
you can't calculate how much WikiLeaks
helped them yeah yeah
October 7th The Daily Access Hollywood
tape came out that's the first day that
the John Podesta emails came out and
those hours after the Access Hollywood
tape just when Donald Trump could use it
the most and those Podesta emails came
out every single day after that for one
month until November 7th until the day
Donald the day after until the day
before Donald Trump was elected
president we haven't seen a new email
sense it's it's Caen it's it's
coincidental or suspicious but there's
definitely something to be said there
about vannin coming in that that
WikiLeaks popping up and Donald Trump
finding a way to overcome some very big
and very damaging and it all echoed the
same theme to I mean all of this was
trained against Hillary Clinton
she leads the the Bannon attacks you
know in the other point I'd Megami Trump
is is so good at dominating media but
the other thing I think we ought to
appreciate is that he was also good in
Bannon was good at using it defensively
and if you look at what happened after
the Access Hollywood tape came out that
was the one time when Trump had taken
over the airwaves in a way that I don't
think he wanted to and they were
desperate to get something off there and
so lo and behold you know Bannon marches
out these X Clinton accusers which was
something he told me years ago you know
he wanted to introduce into the race
which I thought was cockamamie and silly
and then sure enough you know you go
from having this bumper to bumper story
about Trump in the Access Hollywood tape
to oh now you know when he debacle
stands there Katy's point about how
voters reacted you know we've known
since V Okies writings more than a
half-century ago
that Americans first of all tend to vote
their pocketbooks and secondly they vote
emotionally the ideals of the
Enlightenment that the framers had have
not turned out to be nearly as important
as the ability to manipulate emotions
with slogans and advertising and you
know in this country in 2012 90 percent
of Americans had a smaller income than
in 1967 the year I finished high school
and Donald exploited exactly this that
the 90% of Americans have been forgotten
and I know because of conversations he
had with other people that his economic
policy not his racial policy and racial
animus but his economic policy came out
of a trilogy of best-selling books that
I wrote perfectly legal free lunch and
the fine print Donald didn't read those
but he watched me talk about them on
television and distilled out of them the
message you know drain the swamp
your lunch is being eaten by goldman
sachs etc etc all come right out of my
books of course the soon as Donald got
into the White House he turned
Washington into a federally protected
paradise for swamp monsters so David I
come back to you on one thing there but
before we get it's here I want to keep
on Josh for one quick question I was
just in it
in Europe the other day and and and
banner was there and he was cheering on
the rise of the right in Italy and he
was talking to right-wing players in
other countries and you were just
mentioning studies Nazi propaganda I
know he he reads books by some pretty
nefarious characters where's he coming
from is he a fascist is he nationalist
is he I mean you talk to him or have
talked to him what'd you take he went I
only ask that to get describe himself as
an economic nationalist emphatically not
an ethe no national asur a white
supremacist you know he the way he
explains it you know he reads these Nazi
philosophers and and fascist
philosophers because if you care about
nationalism and he told me you know that
that was kind of the heyday of
nationalist philosophy and you know you
can draw strength and power from these
ideas yet in Bannen who before he went
to trumpet fancied himself a filmmaker
if you look at his movies which which
I'm not really a fan of but if you look
these are homage is to propaganda films
from the 40s from 30s and 40s me what
he's really interested in is
manipulating public opinion and that
does he does he acknowledged that in
order for that economic nationalism to
thrive it has to be paired with a
certain amount of racism and and hate
for the other this is who is the cause
of your problem no he won't acknowledge
that what he says is it look you know
I'm leading or at the time he thought he
was leading it you know a pitchfork
wielding rabble rousing army of all the
people shut out of from the
establishments of both parties that
essentially you know you can't be too
picky about who your allies are we need
to overrun the fortress acknowledgement
that it's mostly disaffected white
voters and not and it's and and in the
writings of Breitbart it does target it
does target minorities it does target
women I mean it is it he may not
acknowledge it but all of that is also
paired with a certain xenophobia yeah
well so I asked him this for the book
and in the furthest he'll go is he'll
say well look you know yes this is an
element of our coalition I don't like
that but once our ideas prevail that
that part of the coalition will
wash away that was afraid you'll just
it'll just as they did in Alabama and
you're right and and what they did in
Nazi Germany and once you know and once
people see the benefit of these ideas
and bannon's argument is that they'll
help you know unemployment in inner
cities and the blacks and Latinos will
you know awaken to you know the
greatness of nationalism and Trump I
think that's his way of essentially
avoiding the question or not confronting
it head on but certainly if you look at
just the people who are attracted by his
writing by his ideas and into the Trump
coalition people that Bannon
specifically brought in by using things
like social media and reddit and fortune
and all the the kind of ugly internet
backwaters that kind of emerge to
support Trump and attack journalists
during the campaign a lot of that has
been its doing so certainly he is
conscious of what he's doing some block
that line even if you won't in that you
know straight up this this is what I'm
up to let me get two things here number
one folks have got questions we in a
couple minutes are going to open
questions if you want to straight toward
microphones we will be taking your
questions soon and but I want to take
these folks like how you did that mister
that low-level microphone move but
before we go there I want and when I go
back to David here for a second and you
know one of things that we've come
through it's sort of come through real
big on this panel is Donald Trump and
the people he will take counsel from
really like propaganda they really like
to manipulate the media they really like
to own the storyline right did the media
screw up Oh big time all right let's
start with David and then we'll work our
way back so well before we let me just
about it did the media screw up and is
it bigger than Trump yes okay go ahead
okay so first of all understand that
Donald Trump is a pioneer of fake news
in my previous book the making of Donald
Trump I tell about how he got national
news coverage about his imaginary lovers
that's what we call the chapter
Kim Basinger Madonna and Carla Bruni
later the first lady of France and this
was national news I mean it was just
made up but he got it and what Donald
would do is he would call up reporters
especially a Rupert Murdoch's New York
Post who don't care nearly so much about
faxes about getting a big play for their
stories and once he got them in New York
Post he would then get them onto TV and
they were just made-up nonsense like his
claim that he's worth more than ten
billion dollars how many of you have
read that his actual financial statement
after became president is just one point
four and even that's grossly inflated
and I've shown why at DC Report org
which is the nonprofit free news service
I run I hope you all sign up for DC
report org so Donald has always sought
out journalists who will repeat his BS
and he's figured out who those people
are and if you're like me or the late
Wayne Barrett what Donald would do or
Tim O'Brien is attack you constantly he
came to both the Philadelphia Inquirer
in the New York Times with teams of
lawyers demanding that I be fired which
didn't get him anywhere but raised the
awareness of editors that you know they
were gonna hear noise about anything
written that didn't follow the made up
Trump lawn you protected yourself by
getting appealed surprise well I think I
predicted myself by sticking to facts
he's never been able to show theirs in
fact I mean listen Donald I just called
you a criminal if you think you're not I
invite you to sue me but but what what
happened in the campaign is that Donald
ran such a fascinating campaign you know
this was we all rubberneck right come on
be honest we all rub her neck on the
freeway right well this was an accident
on the side of the road that came with
dancing girls a marching band and
fireworks and and Hillary Clinton puts
up this Maginot Line Trump just runs
around the other side of it and she
keeps saying he can't pass the Maginot
Line and and the news media screw-up was
not asking the important questions this
is not new to this campaign in the
Mondale
Ragan race in 84 if I'd gotten to ask
one of the questions that would have
been gentlemen we're all fathers you
each have five children time I had six
so I would like you to please tell us
very briefly about your last meeting
with your grandchildren mr. Mondale
first well Mondale was quite the family
man went home from the Senate every
night to have dinner with his children
Ronald Reagan hadn't met any of his
grandchildren at that point people
didn't know that and that would have
been the purpose and I can also imagine
all the hell I would have taken for just
asking the question and during this
campaign
nobody asked Donald the most obvious
question that you've been talking about
running for president since 1985
presumably you have studied the Job
Description it's only about 450 words
long would you kindly tell us with
specificity where the Job Description is
written down and would you please tell
us the duties powers and limits of the
presidency it would have just destroyed
him and your time signal is up I know
I'm its we failed in the press we didn't
scrub Donald you know you can read in
the New York Times and elsewhere the
playmates of Barack Obama in Indonesia
the Boise smoked dope with in high
school you can read about george w
bush's failure as a tax shelter salesman
in Midland and his success getting
public subsidies to start the Rangers
baseball team the source of most of his
fortune but you will not read a
scrubbing of Donald Trump anywhere
except in my books okay I'll bring you
in and let me bring and and it's very
tough on the campaign to do and I would
say that the history of Donald Trump is
out there I mean Jimmy Breslin wrote
about just what you're saying he would
call reporters and create in his words a
razzle dazzle presence words and he
would convince reporters to follow his
story lines for four years when he was a
favorite of the tabloids in New York
absolutely but he has also gotten
extraordinarily critical coverage from
marquee newspapers like the Washington
Post the New York Times
I think that the idea that Donald Trump
wasn't scrubs and that people weren't
looking at him in the
with clear eyes during the election is
is false I you guys knew who he was
raise your hand in here if you didn't
know who Donald Trump was on on November
8th 2016 well you did because hold on
because he was he was covered critically
he was also covered not critically there
was a big mix but to say that the media
which is a very broad spectrum of
reporters from print reporters who do
investigative work to Access Hollywood
reporters to bloggers I mean you have to
be very specific and who did not do a
good job and who did who did a good job
I think it's not unfair to say everybody
failed I think we can learn certain
lessons from the way we covered this
campaign and covering future campaigns I
think the biggest lesson more than any
other is not the scrubbing of Donald
Trump because again we were all aware of
who Donald Trump was it is the it was a
lack of coverage of the American voter
and what people cared about and what
people were worried about and was
happening in communities across this
country that right there is where the
media failed me so Katie I I thoroughly
agree with you that we weren't reporting
about what I call the vast majority the
90% which I've spent 25 years
documenting how government has been
picking their pockets but let me ask a
different question how many of you knew
before this talk today the Donald Trump
spent years deeply entangled with a
major international drug trafficker a
handful of people how many of you knew
without reading anything I wrote I mean
the New York Times and I love the New
York Times I was very proud to have
worked there but the New York Times had
the words Trump and mafia in exactly
four articles in the 16 months leading
up to the campaign and they were all
references in passing
there was no the heavy lifting in these
things it doesn't get done by TV or
radio it gets done by the major
newspapers and these things were not
scrubbed nobody called me I offered
every journalist around access to my
thousands and thousands of pages of
Trump material foreign newspapers called
me in wrote stories about things like
the drug trafficker and other criminals
the Trump was involved with PBS
specifically edited out my references to
Trump and cry
the three broadcast networks did not
have it on MSNBC absolutely did and
never hesitated about it
likewise CNN though not as often but the
big papers never wrote a scrub of him
and you can go back and look at the New
York Times and Washington Post cover I
mean you will not see a systemic scrub
of the kind we used to do thank you
David
let me draw a circle around this
conversation and say that that thank you
but you've brought a lot of important
stuff in here and I think one of the
challenges is that we have a media
system in this country within which we
have tremendous media a tremendous
journalists doing incredible
investigative work I think the broader
question which I'm going to throw to
Joshua is has our media system developed
to a point though where the good work
isn't sufficiently highlighted and the
Bannen Trump ability to create that sort
of constant theater is able to wash over
journalists yeah I would come at it a
little bit differently I don't think
that the media especially cable news was
equipped to handle a camp a candidate
like Donald Trump he was so far outside
the norm this idea I think Katie talked
about earlier about every day if he
didn't like the headline he throw out a
new scandal I mean it felt as if you
were a gerbil on a wheel constantly
chasing after these things without being
able to have the time to to delve deeply
into these stories to the level that
that David would want to store that
other people would want us to because
you can't just say you know what I'm
gonna ignore today's outrage because I'm
not done focusing on yesterday's outrage
and that's a style that's continued on
into his presidency where you know
sometimes I don't know whether I should
write today about Bob Muller's
investigation or the porn star and her
lawyer or what in their story Russia we
all share stories that conceivably could
end the presidency or would have ended
an earlier presidency that are like in
the B or C block on the evening news
they don't even write they're not there
let me tick with you on this Josh just
for one sec and that is is it now do we
have a should we pause and say we have a
media system that's that's not capable
not that it's incompetent not
it's irresponsible my capable keeping up
with this and is this something bigger
than Trump is this a are we moving into
an era where we may have more of this or
is this a Trump phenomenon you know it's
it's a good question I mean two things
have kind of risen up in tandem Trump
and his ability to kind of like shoot
chaff to you know distract us all from
whatever the stories are but then you of
course you have the rise of Fox News and
this whole kind of alternate universe or
there isn't even agreement on what what
objective facts are about Trump or a
particular scandal and you know that
makes it even harder for there to be a
kind of unifying national media
storyline around Bob Muller's
investigation or Russia or stormy
Daniels or anything else and that's just
that's leaving aside Trump's ability to
kind of manipulate the media by kicking
up a news story you know announced a
summit with Kim jong-un and maybe people
will stop talking about this or announce
steel tariffs and maybe people will
forget that my staff secretary allegedly
you know abused his ex-wives I mean
there's there's there's just so much
going on it's hard and for the media to
hone in on the serious good work that is
getting done before you get a question
there's one like one point I'm like it
is not the job of reporters on the
campaign trail to scrub the candidate I
tweeted at the time and and told in
people in talks nobody covering the
campaign has tougher questions in Katy
tour I would fall a lot of reporters for
asking softball questions but not Katie
she got right up and asked the tough one
it was why he was mad at her but it was
also the other thing was that that we
watch your show even now there I I see
some shows that have a great deal of
coherence on them I see I did during the
campaign see wall the wall trumps
beaches yeah and and that can be an
unsettling it was it was an
uncomfortable mix that where people were
trying to figure out what to put on and
what not to put on David I I hope I
didn't come off too strongly I don't
disagree with your with your points I do
think that it's hard for some of the
real soap not salacious the real juicy
stuff the the really dirty stuff to come
up to the top in the day-to-day wall of
people covering the campaign to do this
but this is here's my last point social
media has has a lot to do with this
because we live in this 24/7 you need
more more more now now now new new new
constantly and we are all on this
hamster wheel it's not just cable news
you guys are on this hamster wheel as
well it's incumbent upon not just us in
the media but it's incumbent upon
everybody to decide what you want to pay
attention to what you think is important
you have the ability to choose what to
read to choose what to watch you can
reward with your eyes the journalism
that you think is important it's not
just us I mean we can only do so much
ultimately it's everybody the man who's
been on his knees the longest now rises
to ask the greatest question you will
ever hear okay no pressure um remember
when the phrase anyone could be
president was inspirational how do we
get back to now thanks yeah
that see and I appreciate an audience
that outdoes the panel and I'm gonna
give one who most desperately wants to
give a response to that David you do
well I'm certainly not qualified to be
President and you know I really wish we
would get to a society where know
everyone can't be President we expect
you to be educated to learn to have
sound judgment not to be a great showman
well and if I might if I might do a
moderators interjection too when I cover
the campaign Oh default answer to
everything was that he was a good
businessman nonsense I know you say it's
nonsense but what I'm telling you is I
think we might want to also rethink
whether that's a top qualification for
being president sir you were waiting for
a little bit let's take your question
well you've touched on a couple of
things that I think are really important
one of the things I just wanted to get
the panel's take on was you've talked
around a little bit was Russia and and
where that stands in the impact and I
can tell you where my latest reporting
on Russia stands and hopefully these
guys can flesh it out a little bit the
investigation and the Moller part of it
I presume we don't know where the
investigation stands because that office
does not leak period when we get our
drips and drabs from lawyers or from
people with direct knowledge or from
witnesses who have been interviewed and
in the most recent round of witnesses
that have been interviewed I think you
know at least one there's some certain
lines of questioning that have come out
questioning that that haven't just been
to one witness but to a number of them
and that is having to do with that July
27th press conference that I just
mentioned where Donald Trump said Russia
if you're listening it has to also do
with Roger stone what he may or may not
have been involved in during the
campaign after all he sent that
prophetic tweet about a month before the
Podesta emails came out saying it would
soon be John Podesta's time in the
barrel some Willers asking what sort of
relationship stone had with Trump during
the summer was he really not working for
him any longer
there's some sort of unofficial side
business and could that have been a
back-channel in some way to Assange or
to somebody in Russia they're looking at
these things there's also a number of
threads on money laundering you know the
gates and man afford stuff well I'm sure
there's this Seychelles Island meeting
between Eric Prince and a Russian
businessman close to Vladimir Putin that
they're looking into as well they're
also looking into Michael Cohen and what
sort of dealings he had been into with
Donald Trump if you talked to folks
around Trump they would have called
Cohen the fixer
unclear what exactly he would fix but we
can get an idea that they're probably
looking into that they're looking into
everything I mean it's just we have no
idea how far along they are and any one
of those threads or whether or not this
is coming to a close sometime soon there
are hey it before I bring you in David
let me ask you one question there quick
and we'll do this very quickly because I
want to get more questions but Katie you
managed a show right you managed
deciding what to put up the Russia thing
is it is it's the stuff of novels it is
it is incredibly engaging how do you
yeah where do we how do you balance yes
yeah we cover a lot of it I mean oh you
covered it's we could do it all the time
we do it's it's when there's a
meaningful development in it we try to
cover it as much as we think is
necessary for the day but because we're
covering that so much it kind of feels
like we we miss a lot of stories that
would otherwise be very big news and
unfortunately or not are not educating
you guys and everything that's going on
so it's a balance of wow this is this is
something we've never seen before and
this could take a president down and
this is you know was the President of
the United States when he was a
candidate working with a foreign
government to take down a political
opponent that's a massive story but
while this is all happening there's all
sorts of systematic destruction to
government bodies and the way agencies
are run that's getting unfortunately
short shrift for the great book about it
you did yeah so very just it's a very
rich tapestry here which were
seeing a few of the more colorful
threads a DC report we've written a
number of pieces about some of the very
deep hidden threads about this in one
case I think we ran a hundred and
fifteen footnotes for credibility and
and Donald has been involved with
squirrely deals with Russian money going
back to 1983 there's a normal amount
here we're never going to see all of it
but there's a there's a lot this is a
very rich tapestry that's my question
for you it is it the money that's gonna
get him or is it the collusion or you
know I mean job is to bring the case he
can win not the case you and I would
like you bring the case you can win and
Muller who is put together you know
Muller in the 17 people he brought with
him go out and decided to start a law
firm it'll knock every other
white-collar law firm in America out of
business it's the money they're focusing
on Josh is desperately leaning toward
the microphone he's gonna take less than
a minute and then this wonderful one
other guy who we know Muller is asking
about who is in real need of money for
his family's real estate empire that's
the name that's come up again and again
again Bloomberg my employer is a great
reporting I wasn't involved in raising
them great reporting on the billion and
a half dollar mortgage that Kushner is
comes due and come January 2019 very
soon and the effort to find sources of
that money I think could also factor in
the more association and bring together
the issues potentially of money
inclusion this woman's right what you
said anyway back Derek Prince this woman
is I bring that microphone into the
range and ask us a great question this
makes my head hurt I had to make a few
notes after David spoke because I I
didn't realize about the Mafia connector
into that microphone I didn't realize
that first of all my head hurts I didn't
realize until David said about the Mafia
and Trump and it made me wonder about
the journalists I don't blame all
journalists and I know you guys do a
really good job but a question that
comes to my mind is what would happen if
the journalists both print and
television could have an intervention
that they would
- and not broadcast or publish anything
that Trump says or does for one to three
days I think I think it would be a good
idea focus on other aspects like the EPA
I love what you've brought in I love
what you've brought in here this is
important I'll start with a quick
moderators intervention and just say the
emember the press should never get
together and decide to do an
intervention because he's not I don't
want to be collusion yeah
the genius of the American experiment is
that we have many voices and they look
at different things and they bind
different things and that's good so
there should never be United for
intervention and also as Katie says it
is the the the president nighted states
you can't look away cuz what we did 24
hours you have no idea what could happen
and but let me just for a quick if you
went for a quick hit from folks we know
that Trump does move the food dish out
whenever he wants us to pay attention
and and a lot of our media rushes just
to gobble it up are there quick lessons
quick quick things that we should ponder
to try and avert that I think very much
so you got to keep your eye on the ball
the big stories and I think I said
there's been a lot of introspection in
the national media in particular since
Trump's election and at least from my
vantage point to me is that a much
better job at consistently staying
focused on stories like the Russian
investigation like what Bob Muller is
doing like some of the congressional
investigations into this and even this
the stormy Daniels I don't want the
stormy Daniels thing to become too
central well but it but it ought to be
can that pornstar bribed the President
of the United States because she was
paid hush money are staying consistently
yeah in the headlines in a way that that
even Trump is not able to knock out by
tweeting I agree with Josh that we need
to think about what we decide to focus
on Trump this week we reported DC report
has once again delayed a rule that
causes two Americans a week to die
delayed the rule why this isn't on the
front page of every newspaper in the
country I don't know but we need to
focus on what he's doing
not what he's tweeting I think it's kind
of a big deal yes I think it's kind it's
kind of a big deal what Scott Pruitt's
doing over at EPA for instance this
gentleman's got a question how
responsible was Hillary Clinton for the
election of Donald Trump okay quick we
have a couple minutes here so I'm going
to let one person take a shot at that
I apologize whoever it's the most
excited didn't adapt her campaign to his
pocket what he did go ahead no she had a
Maginot Line and he just went right
around it go ahead yeah I was talking to
somebody on her staff her campaign the
other day and one of the the hits they
have on how they did things was that all
of their all of her ads were directed at
him all of her ads were trying to take
him down and none of them were about her
and what she believed in and what she
wanted to do and she didn't go to
Michigan which is very relevant for the
very relevant to the fall election in
this country you know I know what the
Democrats are against please tell me
economically what they're for and and
she it would have been great if there
were a few ads aimed at rural America
this woman here's got been waiting for a
little bit you got wheat you are into
the one-minute zone my friend one minute
it keeps me up every night what is the
one or two things that you think are
necessary to bring this fake president
down
a new Congress you know Mac Mac Smoot
who's here John
can I just ask you brothers and sisters
if you don't applaud loudly right now
you can applaud really loud in about a
minute but I want to get a lot into this
last minute so it isn't the media's job
to bring the president down I mean we
don't put a target on his back what we
do is report honestly to the best of our
ability on what he's doing what he's
done and if the byproduct of that is
that he is a you know impeached or
guided by Bob Muller that's fine but we
don't we don't try and predetermine out
but the question is what does it take to
change this and it takes you to Congress
or or or do that or a talented special
prosecutor or or a Democratic Party if
it was functioning a little more and and
Republicans by the way who might voters
yeah yeah very good question here from
our folks guys on the floor okay we're
gonna do this really quick c-span is
gonna stick with us for a minute pop it
up mister and I will fold it into the
court come on come on pop up okay yeah I
want your take on mr. Kelly his chief of
staff is this an American patriot who is
trying to protect the American public
from Trump or is this a gentleman who is
all in with Trump what do you think it's
hard to get a read on Kelly he he first
of all visitors visitors logs do that
just good because they can they decided
they don't want to do it and they're not
feeling enough pressure to release them
that's just the short answer the the
Kelly question I think that's debatable
I think there he came in with a certain
reputation and that reputation has
eroded significantly since he's been in
there the the attack on Frederico wilson
number one where it turned out what he
was saying was not true and there never
was an apology or an amendment to that
took away some of his credibility the
Rob Porter stuff took away a lot of his
credibility because he's now changed his
story a number of times on when he
knew about Rob Porter and what he did
and how he reacted to it that story is
all over the map and been very
inconsistent and that does make people
question the values that he's bringing
into the office and what he is able to
do remember Donald Trump is not somebody
that's going to be controlled by anybody
under military law what Kelly has done
falls under the category of conduct
unbecoming an officer or Kubo and Kelly
is a product of a media dramatically
failing to vet someone dramatically
failing he said and did things in the in
his early tenure particularly when he
got into the cabinet that showed an
incredible subservience to Donald Trump
and when he came to chief of staff and I
had people saying all the time oh wow
he's going to get the height White House
in order there was there was no evidence
of that
it was terrible coverage it goes to the
problem of horrible coverage of the
people that Trump has appointed to these
positions this man gets the last
question why does the media not come out
tougher on Sara Huckabee Sanders at the
her press conference okay great question
sir much appreciated and we're gonna
give I'm gonna give one of your shot at
that then I'm gonna give one last quick
take where we'll be out of here who's
wants to give us Sarah Huckabee
I am press conferences every day I think
yeah I think we're I think I'm pretty
tough on her when she's not telling the
truth we try to point it out when she's
to her face I do it's pretty tough on
her and also you have to understand
something you don't want to you don't
want an angry mean loud F you press
corps in the White House press briefing
room you want you want a certain amount
of depend no matter what the
administration is doing you want a
certain amount of decorum and respect
among the press in that room because
they are the ones that will be there the
universal question shows okay you're
asking question shows how tough they're
being on her they really are somebody's
been doing this for 50 more than 50
years they are really being tough on her
in that room and at the same time
appropriate brothers and sisters Sonny
she spends brothers and sisters let me
leave you here with
Kait eaters interaction with Sean Spicer
give you to give you a little confidence
in journalists here Sean Spicer says you
guys have an NBC thing like it was some
sort of criticism of you know one
Network picking on people and Katy tur
said yes we do
it's called journalism ladies and
gentlemen please give a big round of
applause for journalism for Katy - for
Joshua Greene and for David Kay Johnson
[Applause]